Can,
I know youtube got like 2 million subscribers.
Really?
Like on Twitter I have 12 million people following.
It's a lot,
man.
That's a lot quells medium people following me.
My Brazilian Instagram,
I got like 1.5 million people.
People.
People are very active in social media in Brazil.
It is good.
It's something that is from our nature to connect with people in Brazil.
So that's why social media huge any was,
it was like an alternative for the traditional media.
What does this the most personal Twitter,
look at you motherfucker.
I got a story on the New York Times.
That's crazy.
New York Times magazine saying you're the most influential person on Twitter.
That's incredible.
Now what?
Why?
Why are they saying you're the most influential would,
what were you doing that was influencing people?
I have no idea.
I was surprised.
One day I woke up and it was a story on the New York Times saying that it was
the most inflammation profile on Twitter and in second place the Dalai Lama take
this one Dalai Lama,
I'll by my third
I was the first one.
So these,
they did like a huge story about me.
Wow.
And incredible.
It was man,
Twitter was something huge in Brazil.
What is the difference between the way people use Twitter in Brazil and America?
Is there a difference?
No.
For for me,
I just used Twitter for jokes.
That's what I did for quite some time.
It was a,
Twitter lost a lot of his strength in Brazil because people like to connect.
Assault.
Facebook is huge and Instagram is huge.
So you have your family over there,
you have a,
you'll have everything,
you'll,
hey you have your people but you feel talking you for just like scrape.
Twitter feels like you're screaming and someone is going to listen.
It's not like on Facebook that people follows you and then if he likes shoe,
your post is going to be like in the,
in the top of his page.
Twitter.
There's just something that is there.
So it lost a lot of power in Brazil.
But one thing that is happening right now is our new president and we have a new
president now that is a right wing guy who was just elect and then he got
stabbed.
He was like,
when did he get stabbed?
There was like two months ago real during the process of the election.
Holy Shit got stabbed in the gut,
like Whoa,
did you see that?
And that was crazy.
I didn't hear about that and he's like a very white rain.
He won the election and he is trying to do with Twitter with Trump did whether
he's doing and here like run instead of going to press conferences and in
everything who just go on Twitter and see what he wants.
Wow.
Yeah.
Twitter is a unique in the way people just use it to insult people and so angry,
so angry.
Like if you just,
only if you didn't know anything about people and you just looked on Twitter and
you just like saw how we like when people must be fighting in the streets,
it must be just a bloodbath out there if you really thought that people
interacted in the real world.
The way they do on Twitter,
you would think that everywhere is just weapons and clubs and getting shit,
running people over with cars,
wishing everyone dies.
But I think man,
there's a difference and I think we have to knowledge that there's a difference
between your behavior on the web and outside of the lab for sure.
And sometimes you don't realize that,
oh,
the ward is boarding is sensitive and everything else if you go outside is not
that much.
It's the same.
It was always a distorted lens that you could see humans through.
It's not how people really are and it's also,
it's not a healthy way to communicate because you don't worry about what the
person thinks about what you're saying.
You're saying things that you don't necessarily even really mean because you're
trying to be inflammatory,
you know,
took to get some attention.
Yeah,
I mean that's a lot of it.
A lot of is just screaming,
screaming for attention and insulting people,
and then you look at people's pages.
That's the most disturbing thing to me.
When someone say something Shitty to me,
I'll go to their page and I see that just saying it's shitty things all day
long,
like kind of life is this man so fucking terrible life.
What I'm doing right now,
I have the series that had one Instagram where I just,
I get like the Guy Kersey me or saying some shit about me and I just show his
face and it's enough.
And it's funny because it's,
it's funny to see who is Zach Kuwait's me.
Then I called this,
the people who hates me and then I put wicked wrote and then only his,
like his face is done.
The Nao.
It's enough for you to see how that's fucking,
you don't have to take things too serious because if you take a look of their
lives it's,
you can see why they are so mad.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of that.
There's a lot of angry and they'll,
most of them have private accounts.
Like you can't look at their pictures.
They're hiding,
they're hiding who they are.
They just talk shit in the comments that showed an bro.
Yeah.
That's weak shit.
[inaudible] that shade.
So we giving people a chance to like,
it's row blind shots,
man,
this crazy.
I think that the,
the being anonymous on the web,
it's a good,
he's a good thing because it allows you to be free at the same time.
A good for whistle blowers,
for people like proporting crimes,
reporting,
corruption scores,
you know,
like that.
For that it's critical.
That is,
that is a,
uh,
there's a way to do it and they'll expose yourself,
but at the same time he creates that,
but it's,
you know,
it's the sign up for the new era,
Bro.
Just a new thing that we all have to navigate.
Is it just a new thing?
And it's like we were talking about earlier with social media being so recent in
human history,
there's never been anything where you could just talk to the whole world and do
it from your phone while you're sitting at a red light.
You could say something.
There's a story about this woman wasn't named Justine Sacco was out the woman's
name who said something racist and went to a plane.
Yes,
yes.
She said,
uh,
I'm going to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white,
lol.
So she was fucked up on Ambien and she was a,
or a Xanax or ambien.
I forget what it was she was,
she was on some sort of psych medication.
Okay.
And something that affects your brain and drank too.
She had a couple of drinks,
just thought she was being funny and then wakes up 16 hours later in Africa and
her life is over.
That's crazy.
Fucking crate.
And it was just one of those days where there was like a slow news cycle and
people just jumped on that tweet.
And the thing about it too is that they don't want you to recover from something
like that.
They want,
that's,
that's you for the rest of your life.
That's what I felt.
I'm the baby fucker.
Yeah.
So everything that I say right now,
it's like,
wasn't cute.
Like fucking babies and all fuck the babies.
I don't think they're attractive.
I don't feel,
I don't feel attracted at all.